oh good morning how did you sleep
oh okay I had this um really weird dream
last night for those of you that don't
know I do improv at the lovely people's
Improv Theater located at 154 West 29th
Street between 6th and 7th Avenue I had
this dream no I was doing improv with a
young group of improvisers like fresh
out of college Oh for all of you that
don't know improv is basically where a
group of about you know two to nine
people onstage at the same time take a
suggestion of a word or a phrase or
something from the audience and then
they create a series of scenes and an
entire show based off of that word out
of completely nothing like when David
Copperfield goes like this with that
blanket and then the motorcycle appears
underneath of it improvisers take a
blanket from the audience and go like
this and then they make a motorcycle so
anyway in this dream these kids had
started a scene um I forget what our
suggestion was I think it was like Mount
Olympus or something so they started
this scene on Mount Olympus and they
were all gods and goddesses they were
talking about um problems and situations
and I had some idea to come on as Apollo
who as far as my historical memory tells
me he was out of God know he wants a God
it was a God but I just couldn't all
these other gods are so defined and what
their god of that Apollo to me seemed so
defined so I came on and was like hey
guys it's me Apollo I'm having a crisis
because I don't know what I'm the god of
and then some kid in the front row yells
out you just ruined the joke and I was
like oh
and everyone on stage with me just
turned and looked at me more
we're completely confused and then I
thought oh I wasn't listening to what
they were saying so maybe I did miss
some joke what did I miss how could I do
this
wrong and so I was freaking out and the
show kept going regardless of that
situation and then later somehow in the
dream were like all hanging out and the
kid that yelled at me was um I was like
serving drinks or something and he kept
and asked for a drink and I was like
you're an [ __ ] which I would never do
in real life and he was like you ruined
the joke you said I'm here at Apollo
when they were clearly on Mount Olympus
and I said you didn't hear me correctly
I said I'm it's me Apollo I have an
issue and he was like oh and I was like
ah I didn't mess up ah here's your beer
I hate you you [ __ ] so I did not
sleep very well last night let's just
say that how'd you sleep